English you have to know it if you want
to fit in this globalized world without
English you would not be able to
understand this very same video hi my
name is Luca from Luca procom and today
I'm going to talk about how I've learned
English and the key lessons I've learned
along this amazing journey nowadays I
use English every single day and it has
become second nature to me the things
were actually taught at the very
beginning when I used to attend school
and learn English as my first foreign
language actually things were really
difficult my pronunciation was atrocious
I got overwhelmed by all these phrasal
verbs and I got confused by tenses
I could not stand grammar and basically
I felt down every time and try to speak
and get my point across to make a long
story short it was a mess but then the
moment came when Susan my American
teacher came and started giving me
lessons the biggest lesson I've learned
from her is not about phrasal verbs is
not about tenses it's not about grammar
it was about attitude my entire attitude
towards the English language changed I
started seeing every single mistake I
made not as a failure but as an
opportunity at door that opened and that
made all the difference so whenever
you're learning a language you're
starting any language in the world
remember to write down things such as
growth happiness joy enjoyment because
these are the words that guide you and
will guide you through your learning all
those mistakes errors hesitations and
not being able to get my point across
they were all there for me to learn I
really liked the quote that says that
10% is what happens to you and 90% is
how you react to it and that's exactly
the attitude I had when I started and I
kept learning English along all these
years
when Susan and I started working
together on my English outside of the
class I realized another big thing that
I was not focused on marks I was not
focused on the performance I was focused
on the process I was enjoying the
process itself a language learner is
like a mountain climber the expert
climber doesn't focus so much on the
peak of the mountain doesn't think about
that he thinks about the process he
enjoys every step of the way and so
should a good language learner do he
should enjoy the process every step of
the way in thinking of how amazing it is
to climb towards the language peak when
that happens you don't focus on mistakes
you don't focus on the performance you
don't focus on the fact that you're
making or not making mistakes you're
focusing on the act of communicating and
there's a consequence of that you're
going to learn a ton that makes a huge
difference and most of us are focused on
performance because we're used to this
school system where we get marks and
we're words out of it but language
learning is not about that it's about
communication it's about life it's about
friends
it's about smiles it's about enjoying a
life
[Music]
if you speak a language fluently you
know you have experienced that Eureka
moment when you start enjoying the
language and you forget about learning
it you're just using it you're enjoying
it and to keep it with the climber
metaphor that's exactly it a climber
just instead of focusing on the peak of
the mountain turns back and every step
of the way
enjoys the view and every single step
you're higher you can get a better sight
of what is down there you can start from
the very beginning I remember that when
I started working with Susan what
changed is that yes I was still learning
English but I was using it I used to I
started watching videos I started
watching movies I started communicating
with her maybe sending a few messages
here and there I started enjoying the
language on top of learning it itself
and this is really important it will
keep you along the way you will keep
walking towards the mountain because
it's not just the idea of walking it's
also the idea of enjoying while you walk
while you climb when you get closer to
the peak this is not to say the things
will get super smooth you will stumble
sometimes you will stop you will run out
of breath and sometimes you will ask
yourself why the hell am i doing this in
the first place but then you should
remember Confucius words our greatest
glory is not in falling it's in rising
every time we fall
[Music]
so here we have it this is how I've
learned English and like any other
language English takes time to learn but
along the journey you have to keep in
mind the three things can make a
difference the first one is a positive
mindset you can see everything like
black or white but it's up to you to
decide the second thing that you have to
remember is to focus on the process
enjoy the process don't focus too much
on the results otherwise like a climber
you will constantly think about the peak
and not focus on the path in front of
you and the third you have to start
using the language as soon as you can on
top of learning that because that will
create momentum you will actually
realize how cool it is to use a language
to communicate with other human beings
because ultimately language learning
speaking language is about living and
enjoying and talking to people if you
want to know more about this I've
written an extensive article about how
I've learned English you can click on
the link in the description box you can
read and listen to the article like all
the other articles that I have on my
blog Lou Calipari lol calm and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you
[Music]
you